[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you very much donna
today we are announcing an investment of
over 110 million euro into major life
program integrated projects for
environmental and climate protection
selected after a call for proposals
covering the year 2020.
integrated projects allow member states
to pull additional funding from eu
national and private sources and so
altogether these 11 projects are
expected to attract more than 10 billion
of complementary funds
projects support many objectives of the
green deal for example the beaudivest
project in contests in france will help
reverse biodiversity loss in the region
through 10 new nature reserves or
innovative financing for ecosystem
services in latvia the waste to
resources project will aim to recycle
instead of landfilling almost 23 000
tonnes of waste per year that's twice
the weight of the eiffel tower the
silesian sky project in
in poland will help the region of
silesia improve air quality and lower
emissions by replacing polluting
domestic heaters
projects in the netherlands or czechia
will improve climate resilience in
lithuania and estonia the focus will be
a building renovation which is climate
action that will also help lower energy
bills and we also have projects in
cyprus denmark finland and slovenia you
will find complete information in our
press release
thank you very much adalber
that's it for our announcements for you
today and now i'm ready to open the
floor to take your questions so like
always please raise your hand physically
or digitally if you want to ask a
question today
yes thomas go ahead
uh thank you dana can you give us some
details about the agenda of the
president with prime minister
moravietsky
thank you very much for the question uh
thomas so um as you know uh the prime
minister is in brussels as all other uh
eu leaders for um the eu africa summit
and also for the informal meeting of the
european council on ukraine which is
going to start imminently
the president has already saw two
european leaders to prepare and to
discuss um about the situation uh in
ukraine and uh she is going to see
tomorrow the prime minister of poland
the main focus is going to be um also of
course uh the proprio well preparations
uh regarding the situation in ukraine so
to further coordinate our positions uh
on uh ukraine and to discuss uh current
affairs
but that's the context in which it takes
place
thomas you have a follow-up question
yes how about a rule of law after the
judgment yesterday
um listen i cannot anticipate so as i
said the main focus
of
the discussions will be on the situation
in ukraine response and preparedness so
that's the context in which they meet
but of course many other issues can be
uh can be raised you mentioned
[Music]
rule of law issues uh you know this
belong to uh current affairs so to be
seen uh we will be happy to provide you
a uh um
a readout um after the meeting has taken
place
thank you are there any additional
questions on this subject
odile has her hand up
is
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
africa
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
yes go ahead
slightly different topic it's ukraine
russia that's you peter isn't it um
just on the meeting uh happening
very shortly
is it correct
that the commission president is going
to present
details of any sort on the sanctions
package and is that package
ready
thank you very much for the question it
would rather be
for me look the discussion uh you have
seen from the invitation coming from the
uh president of the european council who
has convinced this meeting is to discuss
the situation in ukraine to further
coordinate
our positions and uh to discuss about uh
preparedness but i'm not in a position
to give you before the meeting has
started uh any uh detailed indication
about what will be uh said there there
will be ways in which we will
communicate about the uh the uh the
meeting and the outcomes uh but i'm not
going to prejudge here before the
meeting has started about the dynamic
and the uh the main focus of of that
meeting which is as i said in the
broader context of the situation in
ukraine and our
coordination about response and
preparedness
yes please go ahead
good morning andrea mauroffin tombos can
you just tell us if they're going to
discuss
the eventual sanctions against russia
thank you angela for relaunching the
question
once more the you have seen the context
in which the president of the european
council has convened the meeting um
whose main aim the way uh we see it is
to coordinate our positions among eu
leaders uh on what is happening um in
and around ukraine and to discuss our uh
preparedness and and response but i'm
not going to be
in a position to prejudge and give more
details at this stage before the meeting
has even started
yes go ahead peter and just to add
procedurally one thing because there
seems to be quite a confusion based on i
don't know what all sorts of information
or disinformation that is circulating
the sanctions of the european union are
reactive
that means that we are going to discuss
concrete proposals within the
institutions and with the member states
once we see a concrete action to which
we will be then reacting with a
corresponding appropriate proposal
because the eu sanctions are very
strictly and transparently legally based
and justified so once we see an action
by the russia in this case then there
will be reaction in form of a proposal
of a concrete appropriate restrictive
measure before anything happens we
cannot discuss sanctions because we
would be just speculating about about
the potential crime to which we are
going to react so this is very important
to bear in mind so whatever has been
done in terms of sanctions is preparing
all the possibilities that could be used
in case russia decides to continue its
provocative behavior and russia decides
to attack ukraine again or if russia
decides to violate international law or
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
ukraine in any other way indeed peter
and this is what we have been discussing
for many many weeks and actually months
now
in very tight close
contacts
at various levels bilaterally or
multilaterally in the eu and with our
allies angela you have a follow-up
question
i was asking my question because of two
reasons
today
the foreign minister the russian foreign
minister lavrov said that today they're
going to publish finally their response
to the
atlantic alliance to the to the west
basically and the other reason is that
this morning both kiev and moscow uh
basically they agreed on the fact that
there are confrontations serious
confrontations
in dumbass uh between the russian forces
and the separate sports and the
ukrainian with some wounded people and
the situation the tension is very high
there so i was thinking that maybe today
as the leaders are all here could be the
perfect timing to discuss to discuss the
sanctions that's why
well thank you thank you very much
angela we understand uh
of course the context in which you are
asking your questions um and we follow
very closely
the evolution um of the situation uh
there uh well let us be um
very clear
we
do believe in dialogue and engagement
this is something which have we we have
made clear at all levels systematically
and intensely and we
keep on making that clear the president
said it yesterday uh in the european
parliament she repeated this this
morning um before the meeting that she
had with the prime minister
of czechia um
diplomacy has not spoken its last words
we still have hope that a diplomatic and
peaceful solution will prevail we
observe of course what is happening um
on the ground
we have seen the signals coming from
moscow um over uh the last way over the
last days but it's very important for us
to see concrete signs of the escalation
on the ground we you referred to the
reports coming in this morning i will of
course um
also give the the floor to uh uh to
peter to um elaborate more but what is
clear is that we are watching intently
the situation there we want to give all
chances uh to dialogue and to a peaceful
solution and on our side we are
preparing for every um eventuality for
every uh option and this is what this
meeting um of the european council
starting imminently will also be about
about fine-tuning strengthening and
further advancing our coordination
and
on pr and preparedness on all aspects of
what may unfold
very good yes i see two additional
questions in our uh chat um
so david i take it this is for peter if
that's the case go ahead
thank you very much uh sorry if i insist
on this issue
but uh
president van der lion in
tweets speeches and
other intervention interview for example
have announced several times
a package of sanctions that include for
example energy sector financial sector
and so on
and in a tweet after
her
conversation with the prime minister
justin trudeau from canada
she said sanctions will start at the top
of the ladder
first question what does it mean at the
top of the ladder
second question peter
in another interview with some press
agency president on the line said that
you will be ready to adopt samsung's in
a couple of day
days
so
do you have all the legal basis
to adopt
all the package of sanctions that you
have prepared and you are not
ready to share with us thank you very
much
thank you very much for your questions
uh david since you referred uh to
several interventions by the president
herself um including her communication
after an exchange with a head of
government and a recent interview
that she gave alami first to elaborate
um on those and on our position as
expressed
often actually in her communications by
the president after which i will give
the floor
to peter
indeed what we have been saying
repeatedly and the president herself
said and stressed is that we will
prepared should russia escalate further
and should uh russia act aggressively um
against ukraine that means that we will
respond forcefully and we will respond
with
sanctions which will be robust severe
and comprehensive that is how we have
described the package of sanctions that
we have been working on over the past uh
weeks and on which we had regular
exchanges with our partners in the
european union and with our partners
outside in particular our transatlantic
partners but um also the uk uh for
instance
top of the ladder means that we are not
going to go for a gradual approach but
we are going to hit hard but everything
is going to depend on what russia is
doing and we are not going to elaborate
in the public domain we are not going to
announce sanctions against a country
through the press room um just
the message that we want to make very
clear is that we are prepared
that we are determined and we are
coordinated and united with our allies
but the response and what exactly will
be in this package of sanctions will
always depend on what russia is doing
and let me emphasize once more
because i do not want this to be taken
out of context the first thing to
remember is that we are investing in a
diplomatic solution that we believe in
dialogue and we want to give all chances
to diplomacy this is our priority and
this is what we believe in as european
union
any other questions on this matter
david you have a follow-up go ahead
yes thank you
thank you
the question is still
there
is you ready to
in
in
a legal from a legal point of view is do
you ready to adopt those sanctions in
a couple of days
thank you david that question cannot be
uh answered in the abstract without
knowing what exactly part of the package
we are discussing about and as we have
been trying to say we are not going to
elaborate on elements on individual
elements of the package because as you
rightly say and know the legal basis
depends on the specific elements of
substance
that one
can cover through that package so it is
premature and we will not enter into
discussions about legal basis just the
thing to remember and the thing that we
want to make very clear is that we are
determined we will be ready and
therefore we are confident that we can
act quickly
marcus you have a question about that
too go ahead
marcus are you still on the line
we try to have martial
i am yes
hi
i also have a question on something the
commission president said yesterday in
the european parliament she said that
concerning the gas supplies europe is on
the
safe side for this winter and i quote uh
in case russia decides to partially or
completely disrupt gas supplies to the
eu
so given that the volume of russian gas
supply is very high how exactly does
this work thank you
well thank you very much for
this question uh marcus which actually
refers to the element of preparedness
and as we have
said very often
we have been looking very closely at our
security of energy supply and we have
been taking action with many
international partners in order to
secure uh more energy uh gas in the form
of an
energy uh in particular
in order to cover uh the needs that we
may have over the next months of uh
winter uh i think that i cannot and i
will never try to put it clear more
clear more clearly and more beautifully
than the president put it yesterday in
the european parliament i can really
refer you to what she said there um and
she also repeated the same things in
several interviews so in the short term
to cover any additional needs stemming
from um
needs to go through the winter over the
following weeks
we have been
negotiating and we have been discussing
with international partners there are
producing um
lng so the main lng suppliers for
instance uh well the united states uh
qatar
egypt azerbaijan
all nigeria
you we have been communicating regularly
about that the president herself um was
in touch with many of our partners on
this commissioner simpson er herself um
and this has been a matter of uh intense
discussions and coordination between the
eu and the us over the following weeks
um you will remember that we have
launched a a partnership
with uh the united states uh we um um we
have uh announced that following a video
conference um involving uh the two
presidents uh biden uh and um vondelion
and we uh benefit from the strong
support of the united states and of our
other partners worldwide to ensure a
stable level of
energy
and the president even gave very very
clear uh details um with regards uh to
that
uh and basically um we are confident
that with the additional uh
um lng deliveries from the 120 uh
vessels which have been
made available to us
in january so the equivalent the
equivalent of about
10
billion
cubic meters of lng
we have a layer of safety which have
been building through our hard work with
our
partners around the world
the president and members of the college
were also in touch with partners in
order to swap contracts i
recall you that
tuesday morning for instance the
president spoke on the phone
with the prime minister of japan
about the possibility to replenish lng
supplies
to europe and japan
accepted
the possibility of swapping contracts so
that to have more additional vessels
bringing lng to europe in addition to in
addition to the secure um
to securing additional volumes of
lng
the president also referred to the fact
that we have been building internal
networks of pipelines in the eu and
interconnectors in such a way that these
days we can divert gas flows
basically in all directions to ensure
access
to
gas
and lng
across the union and on top of this
preparedness which is being discussed um
and acted upon at the eu level member
states themselves have contingency plans
of course you know that every member
states has a different energy mix some
use more
gas than others some have more gas from
russia than others so the impact would
be different
but we are in close contact with member
states
which also work on their contingency
plans and we are reassured that we are
on the safe side as the president put it
for sure for this winter
and of course
in the long term and in the medium term
our best investment uh and the most
valuable one
is that in renewable energies which are
safe which are produced home um so we do
not create new dependencies we reduce
our dependency on
on other suppliers and of course they
are green so they will be good for our
health
they will be good for our
economy and it's also a good
geostrategic investment
marcos you have a follow-up question
yes i have
so you you told us
thank you very much
you told us something about the volume
and the way the gas could arrive did the
talks also
involve the prices so
does the eu have the guarantee to get
the gas at the price right now or at the
future price which could be way up given
the fact that russia had in that case
disrupted the gas supply thank you
thank you very much for the question
marcus of course prices always depends
on contracts there are short-term
contracts there are long-term contracts
uh so it is impossible to mention
something by way of a blanket statement
regarding the price of additional
supplies of
uh
lng that we would be uh bringing to the
european union it depends on the on the
on the situation and the type of
contract as as i said
any additional questions for us on
preparedness energy more specifically
yes odile
i take it it's for peter
we'll see odile go ahead
well it's it's about sanctions but uh
it's about sanctions in africa
so i don't know if it's uh relevant at
this time
um
what
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a
uh
[Music]
an
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
greek
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes i will try in english maybe it will
work better my question my second
question was not on the specific case
i'm asking if you trust the greek
authorities since this is not the first
case
in each case
whatever
the greek authorities said in the past
it was not true
so basically do you trust in the subject
of migration and such
accidents let's call
them this way
do you trust greek greek authorities
thank you very much for your question
david but believe me that changing the
language is not going to change the
answer as i was saying we are in contact
with the greek authorities at political
level at technical level and we are
addressing with them questions in
relation to fundamental rights and
reports on fundamental rights violations
it is not in our habit and
you know in our tradition nor will it be
and not will it be the case today that
we are making
evaluations of our partners publicly
from the press room so we have
constructed working relations with all
authorities
in the eu
with our partners and we are going to
address
and we're going to continue to address
with our greek partners
such reports at all appropriate levels
are there any additional questions for
us today on this subject or on others
i do not see any so thank you very much
for your questions and for uh the good
discussions you will have a busy day as
we uh well with
one informal european council and
an eu africa summit keep in touch stay
well bye
uh
so
[Music]
you